now the british have it in black and
white the kremlin interfered in the 2014
scottish independence referendum
members of the intelligence and security
committee also believe
russia intended to influence the brexit
referendum to help sow discord in the eu
but they say the government was not
interested that no one in government
knew if russia interfered in or sought
to influence the
referendum because they did not want to
know
the uk government have actively avoided
looking for evidence that russia
interfered the report says that the 2014
referendum in scotland
in which 55 of scots voted against
secession from the uk
was the first post-soviet interference
by russia
in a democratic election in the west
russian
influence is the new normal says
committee member kevin jones
so the question is is who is protecting
british public from interference
in our democratic process well in a
nutshell
we found no one is parliamentarians
suspect that this
is why prime minister johnson delayed
the publication
of the report for so long for years
british media have reported on the close
ties between wealthy russians and the
tory party
especially members of the house of lords
these relationships should be carefully
scrutinized given the potential
for the russian state to exploit them
there must be complete transparency
about any links with russian businesses
at every level of politics and we do not
have that in respect of the house of
lords at present
the committee calls for a full report on
russian election interference
well let's get a political scientist to
cast his eye over this anthony glees is
emeritus professor of security and
intelligence studies
at the university of buckingham in the
uk he joins me now from oxford welcome
to
dw this report says the uk government
badly underestimated the threat from
russia and
the response it required downing street
says the government was
fully aware of the significant and
enduring
threat that russia posed who do you
believe
well i think the government is in
serious trouble tonight over this report
it needs to be pointed out this isn't
just any old group of
politicians this is a unique
parliamentary
intelligence and security oversight
committee uh of very senior
uh mps who have direct access to the
intelligence and security community
and what they say matters
very seriously indeed now you could
argue that whatever a
committee of mp says to a government
like boris johnson's with a majority of
80 in parliament
is not going to matter but
boris johnson's government has already
got into trouble
over china his policy has had to be
reversed
largely because of american pressure but
also because of
conservative backbench pressure so
there is a suggestion that if the
conservative backbenchers feel
uncomfortable about this report
they won't accept what boris johnson has
said
which is yes there was a problem in in
2019
but no problem with the brexit
referendum but here's the thing that the
uk
has this massive security apparatus that
we're often told is looked on with envy
by other countries so what does
underestimating a threat from russia
look like
well that's a very good question and we
know a little bit more today
because the government has put up to
make its case
somebody who was a mark lyle grant who
was
the national security adviser under
david cameron and theresa may and people
should remember too
it's not just criticism of boris johnson
over russian interference
in the december 2019 election there's
uh criticism over russian interference
in the scottish independence
referendum in 2014 as well of course as
the brexit referendum of 2016.
so there's a there's a lot in this now
the intelligence
and security community are charged with
keeping
our political process safe and on the
face of it they
appear to have failed dismally what
we've been
hearing from sir mark the former
national security adviser is that what
mi5
did do was identify four areas of
concern
some foreign like the russians in
ukraine
like crimea like syria and then some
domestic
and in domestic what they identified was
the use of russian money
to pay british influences to
try to get the brexit vote uh
to go in favor of putin and that is
identified as being
putin's interest the uh disintegration
of the european union and the
disintegration of nato
so those two things now mi5 we're told
watched money changed hands
but did nothing further with it so that
is the big sting
you know if mi5 watched the russians
hand over money but then didn't inform
parliament and the government by its own
admission
didn't ask to be informed the question
is begged
i think of the lawfulness of the brexit
referendum result
remember it was a a very small
minority 3.7 percent
of votes made a difference in an in-out
referendum okay that is
another day i just want to quickly ask
should we presume that this is not just
russia doing it should we presume that
britain the united states and
others are also launching these sorts of
attacks
of course of course the truth is ever
since 2016
britain has become increasingly
vulnerable
we've seen britain under attack and
being threatened by
china we've seen britain uh under attack
and being threatened by putin and
we also see america throwing its way
around
it's not coincidental that secretary of
state pompeo
came over in person at the beginning of
the week
in order to ensure that britain would
not
honor its agreement to take huawei 5g
we are in a very difficult place we're
very vulnerable in britain
we don't have friends we don't have
friends
in europe right now and that makes us
like all
vulnerable people open to
abuse and aggression and
an influence that we don't want
professor anthony glease thank you so
much